In reality, as I've told you earlier this
week, Donald Trump has no leverage with China
in this misguided, haphazard, never-ending,
uh, endlessly escalating trade war with China.
Trump's tariffs are destroying farmers among
other workers in the United States.
There is no serious plan to off ramp from
the tariffs, but Donald Trump has to pretend
that he's winning because he's got nothing
else.
He at least needs to, uh, try to, uh, communicate
confidence because the reality is far different.
So Donald Trump made up, just concocted out
of thin air that China called him desperate
to start trade talks so that they can stop
all the losing that Donald Trump is causing
them.
Now, as I've told you before, the reality
is that this trade war is far worse for the
United States than it is for China.
I won't rehash that entire conversation, but
we discussed that earlier this week.
But the real problem with Donald Trump claiming
that China called him desperate to restart
trade talks to end the trade war is that it
didn't happen.
Uh, Trump's tariffs and trade belligerents
have been making the stock markets go crazy.
It's bad economically.
It's bad for all sorts of different in the
American economy.
So Trump says, hey, no worries.
China's coming around.
China called us and they said, please, let's
start trade talks right away.
The problem is it doesn't exist.
I mean, it just didn't happen.
Trump said during the last day of the g seven
in France earlier this week, that China quote
called our top people Sunday night to quote,
get back to the table, unending the trade
war.
Uh, Trump's treasury secretary, Steven Minutian,
repeated that they have been contacted by
Chinese officials and then the Chinese government
multiple times had yet it just didn't happen.
There was, there was no such call.
The last call that China had with the United
States was something like two weeks ago.
Nothing that Trump says can simply be believed.
Donald Trump has also now saying that Melania
Trump has developed a relationship with Kim
Jong Moon, even though they've never met.
I'll talk about that later in the show, but
nothing that the guy says can be believed.
And the problem with all of this is that it's
very easy for Trump, his defenders to hear
that Trump fabricated, that this phone call
took place and their retort is, listen, all
politicians lie.
All politicians lie.
And this is one of the really disturbing false
equivalencies that we've seen under the sort
of post truth, alternative facts, fake news
era under Donald Trump.
All politicians lie.
So the specific lies and provable lies that
Donald Trump tells really aren't a big deal.
The the, the Trump is defenders live in this
fantasy world where they equate something
like I will work tirelessly to reduce the
deficit and then it doesn't work out.
The deficit goes up.
They equate that to China called me desperate
to restart trade talks when there was no such
phone call.
I've said before, I don't excuse any line,
but there are politician lies and there are
provable brazen, factual lies and these are
two different things.
Who Do you believe on this one?
It's crazy to say it.
I believe the Chinese government, I don't
believe that this phone call took place.
I actually know people in my personal life
who lie the way that Donald Trump lies.
I try not to associate with them because they
are just so toxic.
But there are liars like Trump who have been
kind of in and out of friend groups that I've
been in and the lies are so brazenly attention
seeking or for self aggrandizement.
The thing that these liars hate the most is
when people don't care.
They don't even argue.
They just ignore it altogether.
I actually remember someone I knew who would
lie about stupid things.
I mean provably false things.
Uh, there was this person who once said, hey,
uh, you know, I got into northeastern university,
medical school in Boston, but I chose not
to go.
Now I know northeastern has no medical school.
I mean just, there's no northeastern medical
school.
It doesn't exist, but I don't care.
I would just say, oh, all right, that's cool.
And then I would continue the conversation
with other people in the group and it infuriates
these trumpy and liars when you just don't
care about their lives and you ignore them.
There's someone else I remember who said this.
It was such a whopper.
Something like my glasses cost $1,200 because
they're made of some special material.
I know they're lying.
I know there is no such thing, but I don't
care.
Oh yeah.
$1,200 glasses.
Cool.
Yeah.
I wear contacts.
That's it.
Move on to the conversation.
They hate it.
And they increasingly need to be the center
of attention.
The more their lies are ignored or not taken
seriously.
And maybe that needs to be the approach in
dealing with Donald Trump.
Maybe there needs to be some, some lesson.
Maybe there's some lesson in how I've dealt
with these pathological brazen liars in my
personal life that could be applied to Donald
Trump.
I don't know what the answer is, but the lies
are getting more easily provably false.
Not that I had a record setting, a turnout
at my inaccurate inauguration was not provably
false.
Uh, but maybe there needs to be a different
approach in dealing with some of these lies.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram.
Uh, excuse me.
As I punched my Mike people recommending I
get a totally different Mike set up to avoid
punching it.
But we're, we're looking into that, uh, follow
the David Pakman show on Instagram at David
Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Dot.
Pacman.
Incredible reviews of the Portuguese dog named
the WHO watches the David Pakman show daily.
I posted a video of just dogs
to my Instagram paid yesterday at David Dot.
Hackman follow me there.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after this